nous sommes à présent franc direct avec
aymeric glissait secrétaire général
adjoint du think tank millénaire bonjour
et merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
est ce qu'aujourd'hui en ce huitième
samedi de mobilisation c'est toujours le
passage du ter qui mobilise contre lui
ou bien finalement les revendications
sont devenus beaucoup plus large que
cela au fil des semaines
alors on assiste à un mouvement qui est
protéiforme et qui est vraiment centrale
on a un tournant dans la mobilisation
c'est à dire qu'on a comme l'a bien à
évoquer votre intervenante précédemment
on a eu une baisse de la fréquentation
attachement de la mobilisation au ces
dernières semaines et on arrive à un
moment clé qui est celui de la rentrée
scolaire et donc le retour de vacances
où normalement la mobilisation devrait
repartir à la hausse était relativement
impressionnante pour un mois d'août
et donc c'est le tournant en termes
organisation est ce que le mouvement va
réussir à trouver un second souffle à se
relancer avec notamment l'instauration
d'un protocole sanitaire qui a été
difficilement compréhensible avec
beaucoup de contradictions dans les
écoles et dans le même temps à n'était
qu'à plutôt été favorables emmanuel
macron puisque de 50 % de personnes qui
supplée le pass année terre est
désormais 67 % donc il a réussi à
convaincre environ 15% de la population
qui est plutôt des indécis et dans le
même temps il va finir par atteindre son
objectif de 50 nombre de primo vacciner
donc l'enjeu pour ces manifestations
c'est réussir à tout un second souffle
et agrégé de nouvelles contestations et
en ce sens le l'appel de la cgt à
manifester le 14 le 14 septembre montre
ce tournant où finalement on va passer
d'une contestation qui était simplement
sanitaires à une contestation qui est à
la fois sanitaire et sociale puisque
dans le même temps on va avoir un
retrait du quoi qu'il en coûte une forme
de reprise économique et on devrait et
maniema qu'on va être pris en étau
finalement entre une contestation
sanitaires et une contestation sociale
donc finalement réussir à agréger toutes
une opposition politique très
protéiforme avec beaucoup de
revendications hélas cette fois ci le
danger pour équipe pour être beaucoup
plus important et les mobilisations
beaucoup plus forte alors justement dans
quelle mesure est ce que la poursuite de
ce mouvement de protestation mais tu as
mal va mettre à mal
mission d' emmanuel macron
il ya de difficultés pour le ghana coup
la première on put a priori et même s'il
n'a pas encore annoncé il devrait être
candidat à sa réélection
c'est la capacité pour lui à pouvoir
faire campagne à avoir un message qui
soit lisible et n'est pas des
manifestations et des protestations à
chacun de ses déplacements comme on a pu
l'observer en 2010 est par exemple
françois fillon et du mal à faire
campagne pour jean luc mélenchon quand
il ya eu des affaires etc
ensuite afin de plus elle est
davantage
objectifs électoraux est-ce que malema
qu'on sera en capacité de se revendiquer
comme le candidat le plus à même de
faire régner l'ordre dans le pays et de
garantir un climat social apaisé et une
forme de reprise en douceur de
l'économie après une crise qui a été
très violente si la manifestation
continue que de week-end en week-end on
assiste à la démobilisation toujours
plus importante avec beaucoup de
revendications et un pays qui seraient
entre guy mallard et chaque week-end il
pouvait plus défendre cette position là
d'être le candidat du travail de la
reprise de l'ordre et d'un pays qui se
remettraient dans le même sens de
manière unie et là ça serait pour les
beaucoup plus inquiétant politiquement
puisque pour une partie de l'électorat
notamment chrétiens-démocrates et
sociaux-démocrates plutôt centriste donc
il ya une forte importance qui est
apportée au fait que les villes soient
calmes que l'ordre soit respectée de
temps pour électorat de droite et on
peut penser qu'une partie électorat se
détourneraient d'emmanuel maquereau en
raison des manifestations et de son
incapacité à proposer une vision pour le
pays qui soit apaisée qui permettra à
l'ensemble des populations d'avancé dans
le même sens et jusque là la côte la
cote de popularité du chef de l'état
semble progresser en tout cas dans les
instituts de sondage qu'est ce que cela
signifie selon voix qu'est ce que ça dit
aussi des manifestations qui se
déroulent depuis huit samedis
consécutifs
et emmanuel macron en fait à base il
s'agit notamment pour inciter la
vaccination en polarisant le débat en
ces terres qu'il a pointé du doigt les
eau et déclarations très fortes
notamment les portes du gouvernement et
fait plusieurs entretiens en étant très
vivement les anti pacs et en
stigmatisant par la population la
stratégie d'ailleurs celle-ci s'était
pointé du doigt un ennemi copé ont
finalement agréger autour
toute une partie d'un des six qui
avaient du mal à se positionner en
clivant et en polarisant manière très
importante le débat finalement attiré
vers lui partie de ces populations qui
étaient plutôt dans le doute donc dans
le même temps sa popularité ce maintien
puisqu'ils agrège de nouveaux soutiens
par des guillemets mais il est dans
l'incapacité à paiement convaincu monde
puisque les personnes qui pointait du
doigt et auquel elle aura finalement on
dit tout le mal qu'ils en pensent on ne
pourra pas les contacter ça c'est le
chemin et le point de non retour avec
les gilet jaune d'abord avec une partie
des classes populaires c'est que
finalement ces personnels de toute façon
il ya une opposition politique
maintenant systématique elle manière pas
contredit par contre cette population
puisque de toute façon ils ont été
méprisés et ai du doigt par celui
dont je vous coupe et vous évoquez le
candidat probable le probable candidat
emmanuel macron et les mois de la
présidentielle est-ce que chef de l'état
ne cherche pas aussi à montrer qu'il
profite ces réformes est ce que dans ce
contexte de mécontentement il peut
réellement continuer sur cette ligne
bien sûr le emmanuel macron 2017 sa
emmanuel macron qui s'était planté comme
réformateur avec qui allez faire lever
tous les tabous français et qui se
présentait comme le candidat des verts
vole en éclats toutes les grands actes
forts et symboliques avait pas été fait
avec la réforme en scène celle qui
portait un message était très simple il
m'apprend dollar et
la difficulté c'est faire des réformes
ces dames et peut être en mesure
d'appliquer et d'avoir un pays qui
fonctionne et si telle réforme si le
pays est à l'arrêt aucune manifestation
d'opposition politique
cliquez pour emmanuel macron de porter
ce message notamment que merci la crise
que nous avons vécue pays est plutôt sur
une phase de relance et à mal
d'apaisement emmanuel macron on n'est
pas le n'est pas le candidat de
l'apaisement merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation ces raretés
france amiens glisy secrétaire général
adjoint le think tank le millénaire